네. 안녕하세요. 오늘은 최근에 우리
회사에서 계약을 진행한 어 건물들
[음악] 데이터를 제가 좀 정리를
했는데 과연 어떤 지역이 좀 거래가
많이 되고 어느 정도 금액대가 좀
많이 되고 법인이 많이 매입하는지
개인이 매입 많이 하는지 제가 오늘
어 데이터를 가지고 여러분들한테 좀
설명을 드리도록 하겠습니다. 우선 첫
번째로 매각된 지역을 좀 설명을 드릴
거예요. 어, 저도 이거 데이터
정리하면서 깜짝 놀랬는데 사실 우리
회사가 지금 강남구 청남동에 있는데
다른 지역에 있는 건물을 가장 중계를
많이 했습니다. 그 지역이 바로
어디냐면 성수동 이갑입니다. 그래서
흔히 얘기하는 그 연무장길 인근의
건물들을 가장 많이 중계를
했더라고요. 최근에는 젠틀몬스터
사혹을 지었잖아요. 거기 인근으로도
많이 좀 거래를 했거든요. 그쪽
지역을 가장 많이 중계를 했습니다.
그 이후로 청담이나 역삼 뭐 신당동
쪽도 계약을 좀 많이 했고 그리고
이제 나머지 지역들은 좀 고르게
거래를 했습니다. 그리고 조금
흥미로운게 금액대가 보통 이제 3,
40억과 50억 미만이 좀 많긴
했는데 올해 같은 경우에는 100억
이상이 제일 많았습니다. 좀 이런
고가 빌딩들을 계약을 좀 많이 했었고
그래서 20억 미만 비율이 제일 낮은
거 같아요. 그래서 금액대가 좀 큰
거 위주로 중계를 좀 많이 했다라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 그리고
개인과 법인 같은 경우에는 법인
비율이 압도적으로 높아요. 그래서
거의 한 뭐 세 배 이상 법인 계약이
좀 많았고 그래서 법인으로 왜
매입하는지 [음악] 좀 간략하게
설명드리면 요즘에 신규법인 대출이 좀
많이 안 나오긴 합니다. 기존에
사업을 하셨던 분들이 대출을 받아서
빌딩을 많이 매입한 거 같아요.
최근에 금리가 조금 올라가긴 했지만
그래도 전체적으로 올해 금리가
괜찮았거든요. 법인 기존에 운영하시던
사업체 대표님들이 좀 사업 매입하든지
뭐 투자용으로 빌딩을 많이 매입한
[음악] 것으로 좀 보여집니다.
그래서 전체적인 거래량은 작년과
비교해서 거의 한 30% 정도는 더
늘어났습니다. 특히 올해 이제
3분기, 4분기 이제 딱 접어들었을
때 거래량이 진짜 많이 늘어났고 요번
주 같은 경우에도 한 세 건 정도
계약을 했어요. 그래서 주마다 한 세
건에서네 건 정도이 이루어지고
있습니다. 작년보다는 거래량이 좀
많이 늘어났다. 어 이렇게 보시면 될
거 같습니다. 그리고 내년 정망도 좀
살짝 해 보자면 최근에 금리가 좀
올라가고 있긴 해요. 금리가 조금
올라가면서 좀 불안정한 모습이 있긴
한데 그리고 앞으로 만약에 금리가 좀
더 내려간다라고 하면은 어 그래도
거래량이 좀 더 늘지 않을까 이렇게
예상을 합니다. 그리고 지금 우리
회사에서 올해 계약했던 거와 같이 좀
이렇게 지역별로 양극하도 되게 심해질
것 같아요. 거래가 되는 데는 계속
많이 될 거 같고 성수동 같은
경우에는 올해와 마찬가지로 거래가
계속 많이 될 것으로 좀 예상이
됩니다. 좀 핵심 지역들 위주로 좀
거래가 많이 늘어나지 않을까 [음악]
이렇게 생각이 들고 그리고 법인
비율이 계속 많을 거 같아요. 법인이
뭐 대출도 잘 나오고 뭐 세금적인
부분에서도 법인이 유리하기 때문에
법인 매입 비율은 계속 좀 많아질
것으로 예상이 됩니다. 근데 그거와
반대로 임대차 시장은 좀 좋지
않아요. 확 살아나진 않고 있긴 한데
근데 긍정적인 소식은 올해 임대차
계약이 좀 많이 늘어났어요. 그래서
지금 작년보다는 정말 한 4, 50%
정도 계약이 많았습니다. 임대차
시장이 그래도 조금 좋아지고 있는게
보이긴 해 가지고 뭐 내년을 지켜봐야
될 거 같긴 하지만 그래도 조금씩
좋아지고 있는 근데 이제 임대차
금액이 기존에 내놨던 거보다는 좀 더
하락을 많이 했어요. 좀 조정을 한
다음에 계약이 되긴 했지만 그래도
임대가 조금씩 살아나고 있는 부분도
긍정적인 요수라고 좀 보여집니다.
네. 그래서 좀 정리를 해 보자면
성수동 2가 건물을 가장 많이 중계를
했고요. 그리고 그 외적으로 뭐
청담이라든지 역삼이라든지 뭐
삼성이라든지 이런 주요 지역에 어
거래량들이 좀 많이 늘어났었고 BSN
기준으로 금액대 낮은 거보다는
100억 이상의 빌딩들을 많이 중계를
했습니다. 그리고 개인보다는 법인
거래량이 좀 많이 늘어났습니다.이
데이터가 어떻게 보면 되게 생생한
데이터거든요. 앞으로 여러분들 빌딩
투자하 있어서 도움이 많이 될
것이라고 좀 예상이 되고 그리고 사실
지금 연말이다 보니까 뭐 금리가
높아지는게 대출 조건이 그렇게 좋지
않아요. 어 임대 사업자 대출이 이미
끝난 은행도 꽤 있거든요. 그래서
아마 내년 초쯤에는 지금보다는 조건이
좋을 거 같아요. 최근에 계약한
것들은 다 내년 초에 잠금하는 경우가
많아서 일단은 내년 초를 조금 더
지켜봐야 되지 않나 이렇게 생각을
합니다. 진짜 생생한 데이터잖아요.
여러분들이 뭐 그 외적으로 과연 누가
샀는지 어 그리고 대출 얼마나
받았는지 혹시 뭐 이런 것도
궁금하다라고 하시면 댓글 남겨 주시면
제가 추가적으로 어 영상을 찍어
보도록 하겠습니다. 오늘 영상
여기까지 하겠습니다. 감사합니다.